national average for a gallon of gas
sitting at 3 and 61 cents right now
compared to 3.35 cents that was a month
ago now oil prices have surged in the
ukraine as russia's invasion among other
issues are driving those prices up now
across nevada you're looking at it here
we're paying a roughly a little bit more
than four dollars a gallon
and businesses are trying to try and
navigate these increasing gas costs many
are wondering just how much longer
they'll go and if they'll need to maybe
pass that increase on to their customers
joe moller on this story he spoke to a
few people feeling the pinch joe's live
at sahara and maryland parkway now with
more
i feel like we're all filling the pinch
right now when we go to the gas station
the gas here take a look live shot here
at saharan maryland parkway four dollars
and nine cents last week it was 405 here
people who depend on filling up their
gas tank for their line of work say
they're throwing this pretty bad right
now
problem we have is getting our product
inbound green fielding company is a
wholesale flower business near the strip
they buy flowers from around the world
distribute flowers to nearby states and
sell to small shops and even resorts
bruce greenfield says importing and
delivery costs have gone up forcing them
to make changes it forced us to really
shop better from our farms and try to
work better deals with them
to offset the expense of freight
daniel brown is a private driver and a
rideshare driver he says the rate he
gets paid is the same but the cost of
gas is rising fast he says tips are
appreciated now more than ever gas
prices are up they're almost five bucks
a gallon tip your drivers cash is better
back out here live greenfield says they
are trying to not raise the cost of
flowers but have to from time to time
due to the cost of transportation both
say they hope those gas prices that
we're seeing here 409 they're hoping
they don't go up much further but we
know that they are expected to reporting
live joe muller dive local now